it's essential I mean obviously this is
it's it's the key question if you
legalized drugs you would destroy the
raison d'etre of these cartels and
whether the social price of doing so
terms of the harm people would do
themselves would be greater as the
anti-drug legalizes have argued and it's
an argument that so far is dispositive
in terms of public policy I don't know
I'm a legalized or myself I don't think
there's any more chance of quote-unquote
winning the quote-unquote or on drugs
and there was with prohibition but
obviously that's still not a view that
has much traction and if we militarized
the war against the the the major
mexican drug cartels i would have
thought that made legalization less
likely rather than more likely because
we'll get involved in people will have
kind of skin in the game of that drug
war and therefore you know will be
focused on that that's what i think will
happen i mean obviously what's what the
avala dress it's already clear that what
the obama administration plans to do is
a kind of plan colombia for mexico that
is in large infusions of military
equipment advisors money and I mean
that's already on the cards we know
that's going to happen two years from
now if it doesn't work maybe they'll
reconsider but I doubt
you